(upbeat music)
- Hey Wisecrack, Michael here.
Today we're talking about
a nearly 22 year-old game
that still gives us nightmares,
the PS2 horror classic, Silent Hill 2.
Often ranked as among the
greatest games ever made,
not just in horror,
it is influential for other
games and films as well.
Even Guillermo del Toro
confesses to being a fan.
- Because it's one of my
favorite gaming franchises
and story-telling franchises ever.
- So what makes it so great?
And why did its successors which borrowed
so heavily from it,
not quite hit the mark?
Well, it has a lot to do
with the psychological part
of its psychological horror.
So turn on your radios
and grab a plank of wood
for this Wisecrack edition
on the Psychology of Silent Hill 2.
And spoilers ahead for an old video game.
Let's do a quick recap.
Silent Hill 2 is the story
of widowed James Sunderland,
who arrives at the titular
town of Silent Hill
after receiving a letter
from his wife, Mary,
asking for him to visit.
But Mary's been dead for three years.
- [James] A dead person
can't write a letter.
Mary died of that damn
disease three years ago.
- [Michael] So James is
understandably confused,
and decides to investigate.
Upon arrival, a pretty mean fog rolls in
that hides some grotesque
monsters and draw distances.
He soon realizes the town is nearly empty
save for nightmare fuel.
He does, however, meet some normal people.
Well, sort of normal.
The schlub-with-a-stomach-bug, Eddie,
the lost and erratic Angela,
and the really obnoxious
little girl, Laura.
None of whom are all that
interested in hanging out
or being particularly helpful,
like when Laura locks
James in a room to die.
- [James] Laura!
What are you doing?
- [Michael] James also witnesses
the main antagonist of the game,
everyone's favorite geometric
ghoul, Pyramid Head,
doing something to two pairs
of legs stitched together.
Look, we'll get to that, anyway,
he then meets a woman who looks
identical to his wife Mary,
but weirdly named Maria,
who tags along in hopes
of escaping the town.
After exploring a hospital
with questionable health standards,
Maria is killed by Pyramid Head,
only to be found inexplicably
alive a little later.
James further explores Silent Hill,
repeatedly rescuing Maria
and watching her die,
rescuing Angela and watching her die,
trying to help Eddie
and having to kill him,
all while that little jerk
Laura keeps trying to kill him.
This all culminates in
James confronting his past.
Turns out, he euthanized/murdered his wife
as she was wasting away
from a terminal illness.
Both to put her out of her misery
and so he might move on with his life.
Depending on how you play the game,
James can either leave Silent Hill
with the wife doppelganger
Maria, leave the town with Laura,
revive his dead wife using
the evil powers of the town,
or take his own life after
being torn apart by guilt.
Silent Hill 2 is as tragic as it is scary.
Sure, the lighting and
the isolating atmosphere
makes wandering the empty
streets creepy as hell.
And yes, waiting for your
radio to fill with static
as another shambling nightmare approaches
can be unbearably tense.
But it's James' tragic backstory
that makes it all so bleak.
To understand how the tragedy and scares
worked so cohesively, we have to turn
to Swiss psychoanalyst, Carl Jung,
a one time pupil of
mother-loving Sigmund Freud,
Jung believed human neuroses
are born out of the
subconscious which is influenced
by our desires.
He thought of this subconscious desire
as a type of energy, a
sort of driving force
that he referred to as libido.
This was different from Freud's definition
which was explicitly sexual
like everything with Freud.
As Jung put it, "libido denotes a desire
"or impulse unchecked by
any kind of authority,
"moral or otherwise.
"Libido is appetite in its natural state."
Jung believed our psyche was a
self regulating system and
our libido is part of that.
Our libidinal energy or drive simply knows
where it should go to help the psyche,
likening it to water.
"The libido has, as it
were, a natural penchant.
"It is like water, which
must have a gradient
"if it is to flow."
But just like water,
it can meet resistance
and back up.
For Jung, this is what depression is,
a sort of clog in our libido.
So, our desires or libido
shows us where to go
but we have to do the work
to pull out that clog.
This concept is the first
step in understanding
the main premise of the game.
Most people, quite rightly, wonder why
James would go all the
way to spooky Silent Hill
in the first place when he knows damn well
his wife is dead.
You know, because he killed her.
We might also ask why as soon as he sees
the first half melted
figure move to attack him,
he doesn't just turn tail
and run right back the way he came in.
After all, in some endings, he just
strolls right back out of town.
No doors lock shut behind him,
no fallen rocks block his path.
He even has an abundant supply of maps.
Instead, James stays because of his
subconscious desire, his desire to know
who sent the letter but mostly,
his desire for forgiveness.
This is James's libido in action.
Pushing him in the directions towards
what he desires most
and encouraging him to work through
the traumas that are clogging up
the natural flow of his libido.
And that starts before he's
even set foot in the town.
Once he's there, the Jungian psychology
kicks into overdrive.
Not long after arriving in the town,
through a graveyard, I might add,
James encounters a monster
walking on two legs
but with no arms and no face.
Though, it must have a mouth because
it likes to throw up on him.
Another type of monster you meet
has two sets of legs stitched
on top of each other,
an anatomical oddity that might
in any other scenario seem goofy
instead of terrifying.
Part of this terror is driven by how
they're introduced along with the
breakout star of the
Silent Hill franchise,
Pyramid Head.
While searching a hallway,
James hears a commotion
in one of the rooms.
He runs inside and then
ducks into a closet
where he peers through the
blinds to see what is happening
and what is happening?
Geez.
When Pyramid Head's not terrorizing you,
he's jamming a long spear or huge sword
into women's bodies.
And yeah, you can probably see
where we're going with this.
Silent Hill 2 is full
of the types of symbols
Jungian psychoanalysts
would love to decode.
Jung's theory of symbolism was that
certain primal energy is like love
and fear manifest in
our psyche as symbols.
Sometimes these symbols are specific,
a hammer you banged your thumb with
could become a symbol of
your pain or stupidity.
But sometimes these symbols are shared
between all people
and are as primal as the
energies they represent.
Jung called these kind
of symbols archetypes,
a phrase you might have heard before.
- A patient suffering delusional episodes
often focus their paranoia
on an external tormentor,
usually one conforming
to Jungian archetypes.
- [Michael] These
archetypes represent figures
and characters we see throughout history
in different cultures in civilization.
For Jung, the mother is an
archetype in every culture
and most religions all over the world
symbolizing fertility,
the earth, and compassion.
While he saw the wise old man archetype
as similarly the symbol of age, wisdom,
and guidance in a lot of cultures.
Now, whether these symbols
are actually universal
has been contested.
But we're just sticking with Jung's model
for this video.
Whatever form they take,
these symbols express
a fundamental aspect of our psyche
that we have trouble
consciously articulating.
Per Jung, "every psychological expression
"is a symbol if we assume that it states
"or signifies something more
"and other than itself which eludes
"our present knowledge."
In the case of Silent Hill,
we are able to diagnose a lot of
what is going on in James's head
just through the symbolism in the game.
Though some of these symbols
are obvious, some aren't.
So, let's get all Jungian
and psychoanalyze James.
And apologies in advance, this
might get a little graphic.
Don't blame us, blame Kanami.
Let's start with the most
obvious symbol, Maria.
She is an exact likeness
of James's dead wife.
But more seductively dressed
and aggressively flirtatious.
At the end of the game, James confesses
he was frustrated and angry with Mary
because he wanted to move on with his life
instead of having to care for her.
- [James] The truth is,
part of me hated you
for taking away my life.
- So, when James arrives in a haunted town
and meets his wife's near identical twin
with a similar name who is more assertive
and sexually alluring, we begin to realize
she represents not what his wife was
but what he might have wanted her to be.
Knowing this, we realize James's libido
might be as sexual as
Freud believed after all.
So, if Maria symbolizes the frustration
James felt during his wife's long illness,
that puts into context a lot of other
symbols he encounters throughout the game.
Like Pyramid Head for instance.
James says at the end of the game,
- [James] That's why I needed you.
I needed someone to punish me for my sins.
- Suggesting he or the
town created Pyramid Head
in an attempt at self-flagellation.
But while that might be
the monster's purpose,
what he symbolizes ties into James's
sexual frustration.
Like when we see the muscular
unstoppable powerhouse
stabbing his wife's lookalike
with a huge, long spear
and look, guys, we don't want to get
demonetized but you know what
we're talking about, right?
This kind of overt sexual symbolism
is consistent throughout the game.
Seen in the nurse in the hospital
wearing inexplicably revealing outfits
or those freaky sets of women's legs
that are literally
attacking you with their,
well, you get it.
And it's not just the monsters either.
The image in the frame when you see Angela
for the final time is a corrupted
representation of a naked female body.
Before that you find her in a room
that has walls seemingly made of flesh.
Also, there are orifices above your head
with cylinders sliding
repeatedly in and out.
At other times, the monsters symbolize
a less sexual version of James's guilt.
The first monsters you meet resemble
a person in a straight jacket.
This is before you find all the notes
about violent patients in the asylum.
For James, who we learned felt trapped
in his marriage to a dying woman,
the symbol of a visibly
bound creature attacking him
can be seen as a symbol
of the restrictions
he felt while caring for his wife.
The final boss of the
game amounts to a surreal
nightmare version of Mary,
or Maria, depending on
how you played the game,
strapped in a bed hanging over James.
This image of a woman bound to her bed
floating above him, literally
hanging over his head
as it hinders him symbolizes how James
felt about his wife as she was dying.
An oppressive presence
following him wherever he goes
that he ultimately ends up destroying.
The other people driven to the town
by their libidinal energy are struggling
with their own demons too.
Early on in the game, James
reads a note that says,
I saw those demons.
They were there, I'm certain.
But my friend says he didn't see anything.
If that's true, does that mean
that what I saw was an illusion?
The more we talk to the other characters,
especially Eddie and Angela,
we realize they might
see things that we don't
and vice versa.
Not only do characters
not see what you see
but mention seeing their own visions.
- [Eddie] Red pyramid thing?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Honest.
But I did see some weird looking monsters.
- [Michael] They also
exhibit bizarre behavior
best explained by experiencing
some other reality.
Eddie who admits to maiming a bully
and killing a dog before he attacks you
- [Eddie] Yeah, I killed that dog.
It was fun.
- [Michael] He is seen nonchalantly
eating a pizza earlier on in the game,
right after you found him
throwing up into a toilet bowl.
Angela, who we discovered
killed her father
in self defense when he assaulted her.
- Go ahead and say it!
Or you could just force me.
Beat me up like he always did.
- [Michael] Flips between
barely noticing you
and being terrified.
She even mistakes you for
her mother at the end.
- Mama!
Mama, I was looking for you!
- [Michael] But before she disappears
into the flames, she says,
- [Angela] You see it too?
For me, it's always like this.
- [Michael] All of their strange behaviors
paint that these characters are also
going through their own traumas.
Implying that Silent Hill could be
manifesting each person's own demons.
Just like James, they
have a libidinal desire
which has been clogged
by trauma from their past
and has brought them there to work through
these issues but because
we are playing as James,
we don't know exactly what their traumas
or desires are and can
only see what he sees.
But how does all of this psychology
also make it so scary?
There aren't really any
jump scares in the game.
These symbols simply show you what
is going on in James's head without
needing to explain it.
And this is why a lot
of the more recent games
and the movie, in
particular, missed the point.
Instead of exploring the psychology
of their main characters,
they simply recycle
the imagery from Silent Hill 2
that bears no relation to the protagonist,
meaning they don't symbolize anything.
They're still scary but don't have the
same effect or significance.
In the movie, the character of Rose
is searching for her adopted daughter
who is lost in Silent Hill.
While you could argue
the creepy baby monsters
might be some sort of symbol for Rose's
maternal instincts, what
does Pyramid Head symbolize?
Or the sexy nurses?
Silent Hill 2 is still
so rewarding by contrast
because of another of Jung's
psychological processes
he called the cathartic method.
This is the method of becoming conscious
of repressed feelings or trauma
through the retelling or reliving of it.
Also known as abreaction.
One then confesses so
as to heal and move on.
As Jung describes it, "the goal of the
"Cathartic Method is full confession.
"Not merely the intellectual recognition
"of the facts with the head,
"but their confirmation by the heart
"and the actual release
of suppressed emotion."
It's this form of catharsis
that Silent Hill 2
captures perfectly.
After James watches the video tape
of him smothering his wife,
the player finally understands his guilt.
The traumatic clog that his libido drove
him to the town to fix in the first place
and the meaning behind all
the gross, sexy monsters.
No matter what ending you get,
it is satisfying because they all feature
a confrontation with his memory of Mary
and a reading of her final letter to him
explaining her feelings before she dies.
- [Mary] I feel so pathetic
and ugly laying here,
waiting for you.
- [Michael] It is only when James
confronts these symbols of his guilt
that the game can finally end.
It provides a kind of catharsis for James
and as a result, the player.
This is why Silent Hill
is still a horror classic,
not just because you probably played it
when you were too young.
But because it uses actual psychology
and Jungian psychoanalysis
to get into your head.
The town scares its characters by
understanding what drives
them there in the first place.
Their libido that forces them to
confront their past traumas.
It then plays on those fears and traumas,
and because we have come to sympathize
with James and co throughout the game,
it scares the player too.
It takes what James is already afraid of
and represents it symbolically
so that when his inner and
outer demons are defeated,
or not, depending on your in game choices,
James's story is a cathartic experience
about closure and coming
to terms with loss
and sex, a lot of it is about sex.
In short, it takes this quote
from Oscar Wilde literally.
"We are each our own devil,
"and we make this world our hell."
But what do you think?
Let us know in the comments.
A big old thanks to our awesome patrons
for supporting our
podcast and the channel.
Go ahead and hit that subscribe button,
and as always, thanks for watching.
Don't have nightmares, Wisecrack.
Peace.
(upbeat music)